weekend lockdowns travel bans closing
businesses
and staying home these measures to
contain the coronavirus across turkey
have led to an increase in attempts by
cyber criminals
to exploit people as many so to make
payments online
the government says phishing sites
imitating government institutions
corporations or banks have tripled in
two months
film director muratukur clicked on what
appeared to be a sponsored advertisement
for his bank on instagram
that promised a five-year credit card
fee refund
i thought i was using my bank's app i
even received a security code
i'm kind of an obsessive person so i
call the bank to check whether my
application was on track
to my surprise it was all fake the bank
said i got swindled
they froze my accounts cancelled my
cards but 1
600 were already gone to launch legal
proceedings against such
operations in turkey police need the
approval of a judge
but courts have been closed since late
march and will not reopen before
mid-june
and that's believed to have encouraged
the fishing criminals
during the covid crisis phishing sites
have been exploiting the need for
government aid
and schemes set up to support the stay
home campaign
so they're imitating the most trusted
platform the estate
app which people use to apply for state
aid
but the real app never asks you for your
payment details
istanbul police say they dealt with 30
000 cyber crime cases in 2019
but in the first five months this year
the number reached 20 000.
the internet makes it easy for phishing
criminals to operate from servers abroad
cyber police says as more people use
e-commerce digital crimes are rising
they say they are doing their best to
catch phishing swindlers
but the most effective defense is a
security conscious
end user 68 of people in turkey spend an
average of nearly three hours a day on
social media
and while other forms of crime have
fallen by a quarter
during the pandemic it's helping cyber
crimes escalate
cnn solo al jazeera istanbul
well since countries imposed lockdown
measures street crime
has declined but in other areas criminal
activity has increased
the un says cybercrime is on the rise
and is reported a 600 percent rise in
malicious emails
well in march europol and interpol
seized 34 000
counterfeit surgical masks there's also
been an increase in violence against
women the un registered a 60 percent
rise in calls reporting domestic abuse
and asian people are being blamed by
some for the spread of corvette 19
uk police say attacks against the
community have increased
threefold but david wall is the chair in
criminology at the university of leeds
school of law in the uk and he's joining
us now thanks very much for
indeed for being on the program how
significant is the fact that the
criminals
seem to be able to react so quickly to a
situation like covert 19.
um that's a good question i i think this
is um
this is not this is not actually new um
the effect the criminals have been
very adaptive to um prominent news items
for for quite a number of years now but
but the covert 19 has drawn everything
together
um in quite a sort of condensed fashion
and
people are very concerned and a much
broader range of people are very
concerned about this
um we saw spikes for instance in the
tsunami back in 2004
we saw spikes michael jackson's death um
patrick swayze's death through cancer so
these things happen all the time but
we've not seen such a volume
of change uh since covered we heard a
couple of examples in cinemas report
that
just there related particularly to to
banking but how are criminals
using covert 19 and the concerns around
that
to to to scam people at home
well basically um the first the first
[Music]
first approach is to send out spams
which are based on the covered
19 virus themes and they're just
designed to get you to
to respond uh to give your personal
information or open
malicious attachments or or links to
websites that may
may be bogus or may have malicious
software and the idea there is that that
will
then get you into an economic crime to
be frauded defrauded
or they're trying to get entry into your
business system
because a lot of people are working at
home um
some very inventive ones i mean free
passes to netflix something
the whole teenage population of the
world would love that um
and we found another one um
apps download this app and you've got a
supply of covered 19 safety masks
but you have to give your credit cards
as when that free netflix passes
and you have to give your personal
information the other one that
seems to be very very um um
[Music]
almost professionally done is the fake
goodwill payments from the
the government or or the the tax returns
from the
um the tax rebates from her majesty's
attacks it sounds like we're going to be
all have to be a lot more careful when
it comes to looking at our emails david
wall we appreciate your time thank you
very much indeed thank you